In superhero movies, the bad guy always loses,
right?
Well, "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" flips
the script on that a bit.
Here's how Namor comes away with a victory
of sorts.
Warning: Spoilers ahead.
Namor has a significantly different origin
story in "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
than he does in the comics.
One of his many MCU names is "K'uk'ulkan,"
which is also the name of a feathered serpent
god in Mesoamerican mythology.
"They call him K'uk'ulkan, the feather serpent
god."
Instead of ruling Atlantis, he rules over
Talokan, a hybrid of Atlantis from the comics
and Aztec myth's Tlalocan, the level of the
afterlife reserved for those who died water-related deaths.
With these changes, Marvel could avoid confusion
with the DC Universe's Atlantis and had a
chance to create a rich backstory for yet
another culture that, like Wakanda, was founded
by people of color and flourished into a highly
advanced society.
In an interview with the Los Angeles Times,
actor Tenoch Huerta talked about what it meant
to him to be playing a character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that has darker skin.
He said,
In the comics, Namor is the son of an English
explorer and Princess Fen of Atlantis.
He has none of the Mesoamerican origins that
he has in the movie.
But one element from the comics that persists
is Namor's shifting allegiances depending
on what best suits his ends.
At the end of "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever,"
Shuri defeats Namor, but takes mercy on him,
offering to let him yield.
He does so, and the two fly back to their
warriors together, demonstrating the truce.
Later, Namor reveals to Namora that he believes
the surface world will come for Wakanda to
take their vibranium, and when that happens,
Wakanda will look to Talokan as an ally.
"I need to know if Wakanda is an ally or an
enemy."
This is basically what Namor wanted from the
beginning.
The king originally went to war with Wakanda
because they refused to turn over Riri Williams,
the young scientist who built the vibranium-detecting
apparatus, nor would they agree to go to war
with him against the surface world.
Yet this truce signifies that they may be
willing to align with Talokan in the future,
should they ever find themselves under attack.
Time Magazine has stated that Namor will be
returning, though they seem to be basing this
more on the position that Namor finds himself
in at the end of the movie rather than any
official announcement from Marvel.
It definitely does seem like we'll be seeing
more of the character, and that he'll be as
opportunistic as his comics counterpart.
Namor made his comics debut in 1939 in "Motion
Picture Funnies Weekly" #1.
In his first appearance, Namor viciously attacks
the crew of a salvage vessel trying to bring
up lost treasure.
This is followed by Namor's mother telling
him the story of why they don't trust surface-dwellers:
Some of them attacked Atlantis and killed
many of their people.
So even in his brutal first appearance, Namor's
actions can be justified as defending his nation.
Namor often switches sides between heroes
and villains and never really settles down
as one or the other.
In 1964's "X-Men" #6, Magneto tries to get
Namor to join his Brotherhood of Evil Mutants,
but Namor quickly becomes disenchanted with
Magneto's leadership and turns on him.
In "Dark Avengers" #8, Namor joins the X-Men.
But even in his time as a member of a superhero
team, Namor is morally ambiguous.
In "Avengers vs. X-Men" #8, Namor floods Wakanda
during a conflict with the Avengers, in defiance
of direct orders from Cyclops.
That scene was clearly an inspiration for
one of Namor's more malicious acts in "Wakanda Forever."
It's hard to call the MCU's version of Namor
good or evil, either.
He does some extreme things, but in the name
of protecting his nation from a legitimate
threat from the people of the surface.
His actions put him on a similar level of
moral ambiguity to some other MCU villains
like Ghost or Killmonger; they all have justified
ends from their perspective, but do immoral
things to achieve them.
With the movie leaving the door open for Namor
to return, it's possible he'll return as an
antihero rather than a full-on antagonist.